now I've been asked a few times to touch
on politics and I usually don't fight
today I'm making a special occasion
because on the news I just saw the
healthcare reform bill pass or health
insurance reform bill
whichever sounds cooler for those of you
who somehow don't know about this this
has been like the big talk for the past
year it's kind of a big deal but the
question on all of our minds is is this
healthcare reform bill good or bad it
really depends on who you ask
some seed is a step towards the
government maintaining more control over
the people other seed is a way for
families to get the health care they
need without being denied some seed is a
big step toward socialism others see it
is not one thing I learned from watching
that voting session is there is more
class in a first grade team all game
I mean Democrats would speak and
Republicans with booth and Republicans
would speak and Democrats would boo
booing are you serious you can't even
boo in a high school assembly without
getting in trouble these people are
booing and running our country
I mean honestly Republicans and
Democrats have gone from serving us the
people who elected them to having their
number-one priorities be the growth of
their bank accounts and the inflation of
their wallets while they ride their
boats and their Porsches around with
their number-one goal being to insure
their re-election no matter what happens
to us yeah it's just all politics I mean
so many lies distrust in mixed signals
it's like a marriage over there and to
be honest I don't know about you but I
just don't trust people who have
squandered that much of my money over
the past decade and this side can say
that that sides at fault and that side
can say that side screwed everyone over
but to be fair both sides have done
their fair share of screwing but no
matter what fingers pointing where the
fact is that these people in DC that
we've elected they work for us for you
and so the point of this video the
health care reform bill is it good or is
it bad and honestly that is for you to
decide because again we've heard one
party say yes the majority of America
wants this to happen and we've heard the
other parties say no the majority of
America does not want this to happen so
which is it I for one will ask who
matters you the people of America or at
least the online community and so are
you behind this health care reform bill
or not I am NOT concerned with what some
guy in DC with his Armani suit and his
yacht and his mansions and his hookers
thinks about this health care reform
bill passing I for one am concerned with
what you feel about this think of this
is your moment to speak your
mind if you like the fact that the
healthcare reform bill passed comment
below if you hate the fact that the
health care reform bill passed comment
below and we will find out once and for
all what the majority of the people
think about this
speak your mind on the matter in the
comments section whatever it may be I
will send the link to this video and the
comments section to every congressman
that I can if it's for than it's for if
it's against it it's against but they
will know what the American people think
I am all about truth I swear to you I'll
send news everywhere I'll send it to the
president or at least the White House or
at least the Secretary assigns all of
his stuff so for or against speak your
mind my friends the comments section is
now yours